foreign
in detone in Dallas Texas what's up Ann
hey Dr John how are you I'm good
beautiful how are you
I'm I'm okay I've been better otherwise
I wouldn't be calling you
one day and somebody's gonna call the
show and just be like I'm doing awesome
one day one day I'll do that one day in
a year or so all right so what's
happening how can I help you
so
so a later half of my
on the down slope how old are you
okay
by anyone except my children
and I want to know if it's too late to
find that
what makes you think you've never been
loved
well it's not a thought it's I know
do you know in your love I'm assuming
because I have not ever thought that
except from my children no sometimes
your body uh doesn't tell you the truth
because it's too busy trying to protect
itself
sometimes our bodies do a great way of
pushing away people who are trying
desperately to love us because
maybe we loved our parents and that got
us abused or we loved our uncle and that
got us abused or we loved our parents
and one of them just took off on us
um and so our bodies put a GPS pin in
relationships as something scary that
gets you hurt and sometimes people try
to love us with all their might and all
they know how to do and our bodies push
them away
um did the the
or the is do your kids have the same dad
yes he never loved you
never
tell me about it yeah
so uh we met when we were 19 we married
at 20. we had five children we lost one
very early on it was our second son and
um and let me preface this by letting
you know he only married me because I
was pregnant okay and
um I believed when I said my vows that I
was there until death
um which pretty much did pretty much
kill me like emotionally
um to the point where I had to run and
I've been running ever since
running because you're scared he's going
to get you and hurt you or running
because if you stop your body's gonna
catch up with you
I can't figure it out so can I tell you
what I just wrote down here a note that
I'm getting from your voice
I just wrote this down
your question is is it too late for
someone to love you
correct question to you is
do you love you
what's so bad about Anne
everything all right I'm calling bull
crap on that it's not
that's not true
tell me what's so bad about Ian
foreign
from my husband
I had nowhere to go with my children
and so
when I ran
I never got my token back
and they were my whole life I was a
I was a mom and a wife
for my whole adult life until that point
and he took everything from me and I
have been wanting to listen
are you estranged from your kids
pretty much I mean we talked once in a
while I see them maybe once a year all
but one one has nothing to do with me
why not
he won't tell me what
okay
I was just with him
over a month ago and
um
we spent about an hour together and then
he had to go and he just he
he won't talk to me he won't
he says they're just it's just not
we were so close
we're so close and it's all gone
you were so close and there's been a
definite break I don't believe it's all
gone
okay
I I don't believe that with all of my
heart
it's 25 years yep and I've tried
everything I think there's one thing you
haven't tried
what's that okay
and before I say it
I want you to be open to this this one
um terrifying notion okay okay
can you be okay with this and I'm
nervous to even say it out loud because
you are somebody that takes negative
feedback as an identity
okay I want to be able to tell you
something and not have you instantly go
to yep there's more proof that I suck at
everything
okay okay
can we just two friends hanging two
friends from Texas just hanging out can
I just tell you
okay I want you to hold loosely
in your right or left hand I don't care
which one
the idea that may be the way you've been
running
and trying to reconnect with your kids
isn't working can you hold that
absolutely okay so a few weeks ago I
tried to fix my mower
after a while it was clear what I'm
doing is not working
that doesn't mean I'm a bad dad it
doesn't mean I'm an idiot I'm stupid
whatever I just meant I'm not doing this
right I got to go to the internet and go
to the hive mind and figure it out okay
so similarly
you've tried a bunch of things
I want you to
think about this that sun you just
mentioned
what if
every time you came around his body
started screaming at him to go
because if he loves you one more time
mom's gonna take off again we're not
gonna be able and we're not gonna be
able to handle it this time
right I yes I agree with that okay so
and
what if nobody especially his scummy dad
never sat down when he was a teenager
becoming a young man
and taught him
how to have a challenging conversation
how to let your needs be met how to say
things out loud like I feel sad or I
miss you and nobody taught him how to do
that
and so now his body's got one tool one
strategy and that's avoidance that's it
and that avoidance is going to kill him
but it keeps him alive it's like smoking
right It Gets You Through the next 10
minutes and over time it kills you it's
very similar so what I want to do is
enter into this space with your kids
very very submissively
and what I mean by that is there's no
explaining
no
hey you guys understand
it's very much taking a knee and saying
I'm your mom
and I miss you more than life itself
and I'd love to have you back in my life
when you'll have me
okay can I tell you something I've done
that you could tell me everything okay
tell me back tell me back
Okay so
um
I did that four years ago okay
I went to every one of them
and
I told them exactly that
um I even moved across the country to be
near that
and
nothing
happened it actually got worse or more
um the more I tried
that the more I felt like I was pushed
away
you know do you remember what I said
earlier
what
I'm
at some point your kids bodies are
probably trying to protect them here
here's where here's let's get to all all
the way down to the bottom here carrying
these regrets around with you is somehow
feeling you feel protected by it what is
carrying all this regret doing for you
it's killing me exactly why don't you
set it down
I I don't know how
the guilt
the dot dot
that a mistress
um walked into their lives and took over
my life
and left me with nothing
and the way I watch my children suffer
because of that
it's like I can't forgive myself
do you want to
yeah
I want them to
them that's not that's you can't control
that
and if you come back seeking their
Desperately Seeking the
if you put the burden of your Wellness
on them
they're going to feel that a hundred
miles away and they have already decided
I can't carry mom's stuff anymore for
her
you've got to decide for Anne and no one
else
you may have 30 years left
okay oh I don't have that long you could
think all you want my grandmother didn't
either
okay she kept even if I have
I'm going with 30. here's the deal you
have to decide for Anne
I want to not carry this stuff around
anymore yes I did some things in my life
that I regret and the only thing on
planet Earth I can do is control what
happens next
and every time that pass comes in here's
what I want you to do this is old school
I want you to take uh go to Home Depot
and get a couple of bricks
like paver bricks for like a dollar
maybe two bucks and I want you to get
some some some masking tape or some duct
tape and tape it on that brick
and I want you to write down a thing you
remember that you did to one kid or to
another kid or to another kid
okay and I want you to get four or five
of them
and I don't I don't to where it's
uncomfortable to carry them all at the
same time but don't oh don't hurt
yourself okay
okay
and I want you to go in your backyard
and I want you just to walk around your
backyard while carrying these things
okay
and after a few minutes when your arms
start to get really heavy
and your hands start to get really raw I
want you to throw them in the back
corner of the yard
and say to yourself out loud I'm not
carrying this anymore
and I want you to stack those bricks up
in the corner and let them stay there
every time you wake up you're doing
something you see some mom holding her
baby and your body rips you back 30
years to when you had to had to run for
your life
I want you to say out loud I'm not
carrying that anymore
I am loving me and I'm loving my family
moving forward
okay
I want you you're gonna have to practice
taking control of your thoughts and your
actions when's the last time you saw a
counselor
okay the time is right now
I'm worried about you okay I don't trust
anyone I trust no one there will be no
peace in your life unless you open up
your heart to trust somebody
and that's why I recommended a counselor
and not a friend because they are
restricted
through their code of ethics she will
lose her job or he will lose his job and
possibly have more ramifications if they
violate your
um
confidentiality
it's a safe place but you have to
practice being safe in a relationship
again because your body has said no more
Fair okay
do you trust me at least I'm just a dumb
podcast or whatever yeah actually I've
been binge watching music for my answers
I didn't find them
the two the two paths forward here is a
conscious decision every day I'm not
going to carry the past with me anymore
it's just dragging me down
it's not helping my current situation
and it's not helping my relationships
moving forward and I'm gonna go meet
with a counselor
because I need some new skills on
relationship building
and they're going to be a teacher it's
not a place for you to go to complain
and whine and all that that's not what
we're doing we're going to learn some
new skills and I want you to walk in the
door of a counselor and say these words
I need help learning to forgive myself
so that I can love recklessly and enjoy
the last 30 years of my life
okay okay
and you you will show up to your kids to
the one or two that will meet with you
you will show up to them in a few months
as a ray of light
not as a something that like a dementor
that's trying to take something from
them
okay it will be something that is you're
providing light to the room you are it's
a whole new being
because Ann is finally
loving Anne
and you can't expect anybody in the
world to do something you're not willing
to do for yourself
so I'm I'm not going to ask my kids to
forgive me and love me until I love
myself and I forgive myself and one
can't be contingent on the other because
then it's not true forgiveness it's them
trying to prop mom up
it's crutches it's not a new sidewalk
okay wow okay
I don't know if there's enough time left
for me to forgive myself but I'll try
listen to me
you have to choose life
right now you're every morning you wake
up you get yourself on a one-way bus to
hell
because that's where you think you
belong
and that's not true
thank you
don't belong in hell you belong right
next to me hanging out having nachos in
Texas
but only you and only you can decide not
to get on that bus every single morning
and beat yourself up and take yourself
to hell because that's where that's
where people like me go
yeah 30 years left
to start living
hang on the line I'm gonna send you a
copy of my book own your past change
your future I want you to read it I'm
also going to send you a copy of
um I'll see what else we got I'm going
to send you uh my friend Ken Coleman's
book proximity principle
that's going to help you think about
what you can do for work and career and
what I'm trying to do is get you into
maybe not start a new career but get you
into a place where you have purpose and
your value you got to go somewhere every
day you got to be around other people
you got to start saying hello and you
gotta start saying I don't like that and
this is gonna be about relational
practice it's a great
um read it's easy to read but it'll be
good for you okay and you gotta call a
professional therapist today
that's your promise to me okay I love
you Anne
choose life moving forward
choose it
we're rooting for you my sister